insurance companies will look at the
pharmaco economic studies it's so
obvious when you look at patients who
are on cannabis how much the money
savings over traditional pharmaceuticals
the complexity of the plant is leading
to a myriad of therapeutic benefits that
I never would have predicted you know
I've been running around the country now
for 10 years trying to persuade the
public just to look at this and see the
injustice of this monopoly and and how
you know just the absurdity that their
taxpayer dollar millions of times right
now is going to fund this year after
year but botanical medicines seem to
offer the most hope for patients to
treat a variety of illnesses all with
one intervention that you're seeing
people's lives being completely
transformed their entire worldview has
been changed the way they interact with
other people with nature it's this whole
thing of the doctor is God and we're
supposed to be micromanaging every
aspect of patient's life I don't like
that I want to empower the patients to
make their own good decisions about
their wellness I try to just give them a
menu of options of things that might be
helpful and then we decide together
rather than me sitting on a pedestal
ordering them around you know know
someone's opinion me contradict yours
what is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we and what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sake and we're on
site at the beautiful new West summit
the cannabis tech conference we are now
sitting down with dr. Seuss's yes hey
Alan how you doing thank you for having
me sorry for coming absolutely who works
in internal medicine president principal
investigator at Scottsdale Research
Institute and with your mother
Hannah yep formed though reportedly the
only mother-daughter MD physician team
in Arizona that's true there aren't many
mother-daughter doctor teams period
there are a lot of father-son teams but
you know they're not that many it's too
much estrogen in the room it just
doesn't work well but we tolerated each
other we actually that was a fabulous I
was 20 years I was in practice with her
and I just learned so much and she just
retired recently at age 80 I finally let
her retire so now she's 86 and all she
does is watch the news all day and smoke
weed it's like an unbelievable
transformation she's had her favorite
strain is Green crack she's always I
asked him where's my green crack suit
I'm like oh god this is awful my mom's a
STONER now when did when did your
fascination with medicine kick in when
you were young how did you pick up your
journey into yeah I really had no clue
about cannabis as a medicine at all
until about maybe 15 years ago the
veterans in my medical practice we're
telling we're claiming that they were
benefiting from it and I was super
skeptical at that point I was just like
rolling my eyes thinking these guys are
just addicted you know stoners that are
trying to get high and I and it took me
years to really kind of read reformulate
my thinking because I was just so
blocked I you know
when you go through the very
conservative medical training you only
view fda-approved medicines as real
medicine and so I just couldn't wrap my
head around the idea that this plant
that I all I we'd only been trained that
it was dangerous and addictive so we
couldn't fathom that this could be
medicine and I feel really awful about
that now because I feel I was so
judgmental and these veterans were truly
benefiting but I couldn't accept that so
it took me you know really the vets plus
all their family members coming in and
trying to corroborate their stories and
slowly you know luckily these guys never
gave up on me the vets just kept coming
back and trying to persuade me of their
experiences and and then I started
losing a lot of vets in my medical
practice to suicide and I still was you
know couldn't comprehend that the
cannabis might be life-saving for them
but I was you know I would see a lot of
them would you know when they were on
cannabis they were able to taper
themselves off opioids and heroin you
know other a lot of them were addicted
to pain pills from the VA because that
it was just so easy for the VA to
prescribe mega dosages of opioids all
the time and then then these guys would
graduate they'd get cut off their pain
and pills when the VA realized they were
hooked and they would and graduating the
heroin and other street drugs
and so that's how we would lose a lot of
veterans to suicide was they would just
get strung out on so many street drugs
after being you know getting addicted on
pharmaceuticals through their VA
experience so now the VA is pulled back
and they're recognizing the damage
that's been caused by all this
polypharmacy but in the meantime you
know so many lives have been lost and
you know and I feel responsible for a
lot of it like I played a role I was
part of that machine that was
prescribing all these pills but I I
never felt good about it that was the
thing that I remember was that I always
these pills is very toxic and so I
always would try to seek alternatives
but there was really nothing else in the
mainstream that was you know that was
realistic and then and that's how we
started getting becoming aware of
cannabis and and started seeing you know
when I had this incredible gift to
partner with maps
you know when Rick Doblin first found me
I don't know if that's been like 14
years ago now I think when he first saw
me working on the legalization campaign
in Arizona and he was looking for a
principal investigator for a cannabis
trial and and that's how it all began
and so I'm so grateful to him because he
really put me on this path that
examining plant based medicines and
realizing that there's more than just
fda-approved medicine Siddhant so plus
all the veterans that you had coming to
you and telling you about their
experiences yes and that changing him
and plus also losing some time oh yeah
we lost so many and I mean it was
heartbreaking to work with the families
after we have this charity called grasp
where this the parents who've lost
children come together to console each
other and I would go to these meetings
just riddled with guilt because I felt
like I was part of that machine you know
that was pummeling them with all these
prescriptions and I was I'm so desperate
to find now medically active plants that
could be a substitute for these really
difficult you know toxic pharmaceuticals
and so I'm you know I'm not anti Pharma
I just frustrated Pharma because it
feels like they're suppressing work like
this you know when people are trying to
put plant-based medicines through the
FDA process I feel like Pharma is
playing a role in stonewalling this work
even though it's not obvious right
they're not coming out publicly and
saying that but by writing giant PAC
checks to electeds who we know or
opposed
to this and keeping the the campaign
contributions flowing all that we can't
even track that anymore right since the
supreme court you know the Citizens
United decision we can't follow all this
dark money anymore we used to be able to
see this money trail going from Pharma
to elected it's from private prisons to
elect it's all that but now all you have
are these independent expenditure
committees you don't even know how them
abut we know that their history their
tradition has always been to target
electeds that they know are gonna keep
like what we just talked about here at
new west keeping this government
enforcement ah Polly at the University
of Mississippi you know that will
guarantee that cannabis research is
never allowed to flourish in the u.s. as
long as University of Mississippi is the
only federally illegal drug supply for
every cannabis clinical trial in the
nation means that we'll never be able to
fully understand cannabis as a medicine
through controlled trials while other
countries will just dominate the
research that's it they're already all
these foreign countries are miles ahead
of us and at this point we may never be
able to catch up because they all have
multiple growers for research they're
able to study diverse phenotypes that
are real real-world cannabis readily
available in all their markets and and
even if the DEA announced tomorrow that
they were really going to process these
applications it would still take these
companies years to get up and running
you know it's not like they're just
magically poof there they've got
cannabis to sell to scientists it's
gonna take years for them to if you know
multiple grow cycles before they reach
what the government considers GMP grade
cannabis so I'm worried that you know
we're falling so far behind and that's
why a lot of our work is involved with
you know partnering with foreign
entities to try to do this research
because other countries where it's
federally legal it's so much more
permissive the environment to move
forward and so we could part
with people in Australia with Columbia
all these groups that are already
federally legal but in the meantime you
know these guys the patients in our
country are going to be stuck with a
full the full freight the full cost of
this cannabis because insurance
companies will never pay for this until
it's FDA approved so that's been the
problem I've had a couple instances I
will admit where we've gotten disability
insurance to to pay it's like a single
case agreement where a patient can get
their cannabis paid for but the
insurance company only reimburses the
patient they're not gonna pay the
dispensary so and that's fine but it's a
good start now it gives me some hope
that maybe insurance companies will look
at the pharmaco economic studies it's so
obvious when you look at patients who
are on cannabis how much the money
savings over traditional pharmaceuticals
know take us into this period of the
last fourteen years of what you've been
doing in the industry as a physician how
you've been leading that yeah I you know
the the challenge when you know maps and
I began trying to spearhead the study
and we realized we were like just
systematically impeded by the government
at every step we it was taking so many
years that I that's when I started
partnering with the industry serving as
a volunteer medical director for all
these different license holders around
the country and so at this point now I'm
a medical director in 17 states I
counted from Hawaii to you know all the
way to New Jersey and all these states
in between I'm helping guide these
industry folks on how to manage their
operations from a medical from a health
perspective how to promote wellness but
also minimize side-effects how to how to
educate patients about you know call how
to carefully use cannabis and minimum
is the adverse event so so that's been
my role and that's how I've learned most
about cannabis because if I was just
waiting for the study to get approved
you know I would have lost all these
years of the chance so working with
these license holders has given me a
chance to be with patients on the fright
frontlines which has been great I've
learned so much from them about all the
different formulations and how it
affects them and the one thing I've I've
really all the complex health and
wellness benefits I didn't understand
how you know the complexity of the plant
is leading to a myriad of therapeutic
benefits that I never would have
predicted and it's added you know more
and more curiosity for me and and kind
of driven me toward this litigation
against the DEA because now I'm
realizing that there's all these unique
delivery methods that I can't even
access through the current monopoly like
for instance there's so many patients
that claim that juicing raw cannabis
flour it benefits them and especially
people who have autoimmune diseases like
arthritis or inflammatory bowel disease
things like that they're juicing the
plant and then drinking it and they're
getting way better results than anything
I could produce by writing the scripts
for steroids and other things so so I've
been really persuaded by that but yet I
could never get fresh flour to study
from University of Mississippi they just
don't have any provision for that and
that's why it's so essential that we end
this monopoly and that we get private
growers like with maps has a partnership
with University of Massachusetts and Lao
Kraker and dr. craker is the most
deserving scientist I know for receiving
a federal you know Schedule one license
to grow for research it would be
incredible if I could buy cannabis from
him and by you know his fresh flower you
know right off the harvest and be able
to administer that to patients for
juicing because I want to be able to
replicate what they're doing and I could
old trial so I can understand I'd like
to measure a lots of things like the
pharmacokinetics of of how the orally
you know ingested cannabis flower is
being absorbed into the blood and the
urine and and to be able to document the
the cytokines you know how the fresh
flower is affecting the inflammatory
pathway why is it that these people are
getting such remarkable results I'm just
mystified by that for every single one
of the possibilities with the ingestion
or the topical or however it is the
application of different cannabinoids
different dosages for all of the
different health and wellness benefits
therapeutic effects we need to more
rapidly create the process of being able
to run the controlled tests and trials
we have to because otherwise um the
patients I mean that's what patients
tell me all the time see we don't need
your trials because we know it's helping
so and I agree with them that you know I
I support their how do I say this like I
understand that their subjective
experiences with and their the way
they're benefiting but but I deal with a
medical community that's very
conservative thinking and and when
you're dealing with health departments
or elected officials you have to have
data from randomized control trials
that's it but the sad thing is like with
the veterans study I did with maps ten
years it took us to get that trial
across the finish line so I understand
why patients can't wait for that like
they need safe legal access to lab
tested cannabis now they can't wait for
the results of FDA controlled trials but
you just took this into your hands and
said I'm going to sue the DEA because of
the monopoly on the University of
Mississippi on the use of production of
cannabis that is then being used for all
the clinical trials right I mean this
was something that maps has been working
on for two decades now they've been
striving to dis
mantled this monopoly and persuade the
government to license other growers but
their initial litigation was was
successful but then lost on appeal so
this is just so unjust that the
government perpetuating this monopoly
using our taxpayer dollars to allow you
know this monopoly the the all the
apathy also that's bread for monopolies
so so all I was doing was trying to riff
off of what Rick Doblin and the team at
maps has been doing all this time which
is they've been trying to use the court
system for a remedy that this monopoly
it wasn't successful initially they had
a partnership with a law firm that was
you know it's tough when these law firms
take cases pro bono you know you're not
going to be their top priority so I was
really fortunate to you know be able to
identify this this really dedicated
young you know law team that came you
know that jumped on board as soon as
they heard the story when we you know
I've been running around the country now
for ten years trying to persuade the
public just to look at this and see the
injustice of this monopoly and and how
you know that just the absurdity that
their taxpayer dollar millions of
taxpayer dollars going to fund this year
after year and so I'm trying to ignite
this national conversation and suddenly
there happened to be these two young
attorneys that heard the message at a
lecture that South by Southwest and said
we need to help her she's you know and
how rare like it's so unusual to find
attorneys that want to do something
without being paid and they just sensed
that this was a massive aligned with
them spiritual yeah that's it they said
this is an attack on scientific freedom
and we have to fix this and they knew
that they had the skills to do it and
the fact that they weren't involved in
cannabis at all they never had a
cannabis client they just felt so
strongly that this needed to be fixed so
it's great to see that gives you like it
kind of renews your faith and Hugh Mann
because lawyers get such a bad rep for
being greedy and these guys are the
opposite and they manage to persuade
their law firm which is super
conservative firm in Texas to to let
them take this on and they've been
really pleased with the how much
traction they've been getting and even
you know the team at maps has just
encouraged you know maps it's got to be
so laser focused right now on getting
MDMA through the FDA approval process
they were happy to have somebody else
you know kind of grab this baton and run
with it I think Rick is really pleased
to see this moving forward you know and
he's been hugely supportive because this
was really his vision he taught me about
the the unfairness of the monopoly and
and trained us to to fight against us
and that's the best thing about working
for maps for a non-profit is that they
allow you to have political opinions and
express them they actually nurture that
whereas with other you know if I had
another study sponsor they wouldn't be
so welcoming of that attitude and you
could see what happened to us at the
University of Arizona when we had
political opinions and expressed them at
the legislature or anywhere we could
find we ultimately the university
terminated me and the study and left us
homeless for you know over a year we
were struggling to find a new location
but now we ended up in this great you
know giant log cabin in the middle of
Cave Creek Arizona where we're you know
we've created a really therapeutic
environment for patients to come and and
and get you know and participate in
clinical trials but also what we're
hoping is that will be a home for MDMA
expanded access that's my real dream is
to be able to decide by side to have the
canvas clinical trials alongside of an
expanded access clinic where patients
could go and get you know potentially
life-saving treatment through
mdma-assisted therapy and I know we have
a long way to go
you know to get all the approvals in
place for that but I'm hoping by the end
of 2020 that we'll be able to report you
know start recruiting patients and
seeing if we can provide that and then
down the road who knows what opening up
other doors for medically active plants
besides you know maybe psilocybin or
ayahuasca whatever we can find but the
ideas that the criminate yes out of all
what he's doing and he's like lighting a
fire under all these states to see that
this is not right you know but wasting
taxpayer dollars chasing people but for
a natural plant is insane and and it's
just inhumane so I think yeah I'm hoping
that eventually we're gonna see all of
these plant based medicines getting
through the FDA approval process and
really giving Pharma a big competition
because Pharma is getting very lazy like
you're seeing all that they're do
they're not really creating novel
medications any we're not seeing new
mechanisms of action all they're doing
is reformulating their same old
molecules andrey patenting them so they
can continue to make tons of money
whereas you know I think plant but
botanical medicines seem to offer the
most hope for patients to treat a
variety of illnesses all with one
intervention that's to me the most
exciting and that's why you know my
enthusiasm for cannabis research has
waned so much because I'm looking at the
data from you know our controlled trial
where we were forced to use government
cannabis and you know the results are
really disappointing and and whereas
when you look at the data for maps at
Phase two trial with MDMA and it's
extraordinary you're seeing people's
lives being completely transformed their
entire worldview has been changed the
way they interact with other people with
nature it's just and I think
probably the most hope I have is for
palliative care right so because that's
the bulk of my I'm an internal medicine
doc so I do a lot of work with people at
the end of life and a lot of work with
hospice and hospice has not been open to
this yet but I'm I'm eager to see as we
get these drugs through FDA approval
that may they'll finally start to
embrace this because when you're at the
end of life and your fate you or your
struggling with this what we got this
existential anxiety just riddled with
brutal fear of death that does not
respond to benzodiazepines and stuff
like that the chance that instead of
pummeling these people with morphine and
all these super sedating meds the chance
that they could be utilizing
psychedelics carefully judiciously to to
relieve themselves of that that that
existential anxiety just melts away with
LSD and MDMA and suddenly these people
are no longer afraid they're able to
enjoy their families and be with you
know really engage with their families
as they face death and I'm I've already
put that in my how do you call that my
power of attorney and yeah I mean I
basically instructed my power of
attorney at when I'm at the end of my
life that I want to be dosed with if I'm
in a vegetative state and I'm not able
to to request this that I want that
because I know that I've seen the way
these people have just have have begun
you know it's almost like a whole new
chapter where they're able to really get
through death without and they they talk
about love and light and it's a whole
nother person and so I'm really excited
by that and I think that eventually the
the classically trained psychiatrists
will start to embrace this - just like
ketamine you know got a pretty sure it's
a pharmaceutical grade s ketamine but
it's still a step in the right where
psychedelics now be
fda-approved and hopefully we'll see
that door continue to crack open you
really seen this from top down in so
many different ways I love it so I know
I especially you know when you take us
through that the trajectory of like
where it's going through both you know
yourself doing clinical trials for
cannabis yeah and so that's you guys
doing this and then all the way to you
know this future where you also see a
part of our debt the process of planning
our death has process I mean these are
things that are we don't talk about the
anymore and make them more common to
talk about in and what properties does a
cannabis and and the use of antigens
have on our spiritual ascension that's
and what can that do for our global
harmony and unity and prosperity and
maximizing people's creativity and
abilities and so I want to know from you
though this is well this one's really
important is what we've been asking this
quite a bit the question is this
emerging market has a kind of it's
actually quite important that
specifically this one as well as like
decentralization technology blockchain
cryptocurrency technologies I think that
one - yeah that these emerging markets
that the fruits become distributed and
democratized rather than concentrated so
huh how do you see the inclusive stake
holding fabric that can be made in order
to ensure that's the thing that scares
me the most is that this becomes a
treatment only for people of wealth
because right now until it gets FDA
approved and health insurance pays for
it it's gonna people are going to be
self paying on treatments it may cost
ten to fifteen thousand dollars per
patient and that means that it will be
highly exclusive I'm hoping like in our
clinic we hope to charge people of with
a high high net worth to try to charge
them double the amount so that they can
help pay for indigent patients that
wouldn't normally be able to afford it
but that's the only
mechanism I can think of right now until
we finally get health insurance coverage
and even then you know coverage is gonna
be difficult it will probably require
prior authorization and you know how
doctors hate to go through these extra
layers of bureaucracy but we have to
push for that because otherwise this
will become it'll either become you know
strictly for patients in the underground
who can pay a lesser price or it'll be
for people of wealth and the other folks
won't have access and we have millions
of patients who are suffering with PTSD
we don't have any new treatments in 18
years the US has never approved a new
treatment since Prozac I'm sorry since
paxil and Zoloft
so we're desperate to find new you know
interventions but if we aren't careful
yeah it'll end up being just for people
of means and I hate to think about that
and we also have another issue that you
know how do we like in Arizona I work
very extensively with the Native
American community I do telemedicine
with the tribes and the tribes many of
them already employ psychically active
plants in their ceremonies so they're
already familiar with things like peyote
and ayahuasca and things but they the
problem is that some of these other like
when it comes to something like MDMA
they're not open to that and I am
worried that that they will like because
we don't have Native American therapists
like it's gonna be so crucial that the
the teams of therapists that are trained
over the next five years
have to represent people of color and
all different factions of our
communities because otherwise if if the
therapist don't reflect that then it's
gonna be unlikely we can bring those
people into those clinics and get them
to accept the treatment because they
won't be trusting of us you know if it's
just a bunch of white people that are
saying no this is good for you I'm
the tribes have been through that before
and they know how that turned out when
they trusted white people so so it's
gonna be really crucial that and I know
Maps is making that a high priority in
the way they're training people are
trying to create scholarships for people
of color to get trained as a priority so
that we can have a very diverse
therapist community right out of the
gate and that way we can you know
persuade whether it's you know there's
still tons of of antiquated ideas from
especially in communities like
african-american Native American
communities that are that are skeptical
about the potential of MDMA as medicine
and we're gonna have to do a lot of
education to make them realize that this
is legitimate medicine so I'm hoping
that by starting by making sure the
therapy teams are diverse is going to be
the first step and then doing tons of
outreach in the communities little you
know kind of mini town halls and round
tables with them really sitting down
with them at dinner and explaining what
what the how this can work you know like
especially in Native American
communities so there's so much trauma
there at all levels trauma is like day
in and day out for them and if MDMA
could or or psilocybin or what it could
be a potential therapy then we've got to
make that available to them and and
we've got to find ways to reduce the
cost of the treatment right now its
massive and if there's any way maps can
slowly pare down the number of hours
that are really needed to do the you
know pre-flight training and the you
know post integration or if there's ways
for them to think about group therapy
settings or employing telemedicine those
are all things that might be able to
reduce costs but yeah we have to think
very shrewdly otherwise it's going to
end up being a very narrow group of
people that benefit
do you see this since you have such a
macro perspective on things do you see
this as a massive awakening consciously
spiritually of the entire planet to rise
to the Grand Challenges that are
upcoming I I am really impressed with
how this has taken off but there's still
a massive amount of uninformed people so
there's the groups that have
experimented with this who already are
enlightened and they know the value of
psychedelics but then there's still tons
especially in the older generations that
are not ready to embrace the idea
because there was so much you know
cultural misinformation out of the 60s
and 70s that has colored people's
thinking for decades after now and you
know let's say our government waged a
really you know shrewd campaign against
psychedelics for so many years and it's
gonna be tough to to change that
trajectory but that's why the data is so
cuz with science I'm hoping you know if
we can get date rigorous controlled data
published in peer-reviewed medical
journals that's gonna be able to
game-changer yeah I think world news for
sure progress happened faster and
getting elected officials to make make
decisions based on science rather than
hysteria and old emotions and so it's
the best thing that happens is by the
more and more people who are trying it
they're being transported for instance
in my case I've never tried any
psychedelics yet I still have not had
that but I intend to have it next year
I'm getting ready to become an MDMA
therapist to be able to work in my own
clinic and part of the maps training is
that you have to actually use you have
to go through an MDMA session with the
trained therapist so that you can
experience that and then you have the
empathy then to guide people later so
I'm so happy that maps design the
training that way that you go through
the
eat of the training beforehand and then
you actually get to dose them in May in
a structured environment so I'm really
looking forward because I wasn't well I
was afraid to use MDMA outside of that
type of structured environment but now
they're giving me a chance to do so I
think I can't wait to talk to you
afterwards because I have a strong
suspicion that I will also be you know
very you know my mindset will be
completely different afterward and I'm
hopeful about that because I want to
know what that's about and I want to be
able to guide patients through that
later so but yeah I mean so all of the
insight I have is just from observing
patients all these years I've spent
hours and hours with patients and and
friends and colleagues who've used
psychedelic I've learned from them and
I've asked questions over and over to
try to gain understanding and yeah I
mean I think that all of us are have
tons of hope for psychedelics to cure
more than just medical conditions but of
course to provide spiritual growth to
cure you know big conflicts like you
know you think about the conflicts in
the Middle East my parents are Israeli
so I know firsthand how how how brutal
that is you know what's happened for so
many decades there is seems impenetrable
like how could we possibly fix this
we've had all kinds of you know
interventions from government elected
officials and treaties and nothing has
helped and so you wonder what can change
people biologically that could make them
open to having a humane discussion with
someone I mean I know that when I was
you know if most Israelis are raised to
believe that the Arabs that they're
surrounded by are are their enemy and
that they could never trust them or be
able to have relationships with them you
know friendships
and and so the idea that psychedelics
could provide them the opportunity to to
have meaningful interactions and realize
that they're not the enemy is it's a
wonderful concept and I'm hoping we get
to you know I'm hoping that governments
will employ psychedelics in that way
later but I don't know it's gonna take a
lot of work and that's why it's so great
that Maps is doing the MDMA want one of
their clinical trial sites is in Israel
and maybe someday they'll be in
Palestine and we'll be able to start
bringing people together to get this
myriad of health and wellness benefits
of spiritual growth benefits that to
have the fruits of the emerging market
be democratized its we're gonna require
a lot of you know protocol like
regulatory shifts you know these
clinical trials to see to continue like
you said this big literally stop with
the monopoly it with the Mississippi so
that we can continue doing these right
again these randomized control trials
can we continue doing the things that we
need to do in order to ensure that the
awakening can happen as fast as possible
okay one question that we like asking
our guests and the way out of the show
and then we'll revisit and we'll do
round two again and then we'll do a
deeper dive right course we'll go deeper
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world I mean I have to say
for me it's um
this is gonna sound super cheesy but the
thing that makes me happiest is watching
live theater I know it sounds great but
I've I've always been completely
enamored with watching people play out
their you know stories on stage and and
just the joyfulness of like live
musicals and things like that so for me
that's beauty is watching live art
playing out on stage and
and seeing people have these like almost
euphoric experiences and then that that
real subtle interaction with the
audience and breaking the fourth wall
itself so to me that's like brings
meaning to my life personally and just
like isn't this itself you don't have to
have costumes and all that and but I
mean I think when in theater as a planet
they say all the world's a stage and
we're all actors so this is it we're
doing it right now so yeah I would say
that's beauty there's the connection
between why you like that is because you
yourself playing that's it I play player
character yeah we do I mean I'm you know
as doctors you know we feel like we're
often it's it's it seems that we're
actors but I've always been resisted
that because I feel like being with the
patient means you've got to be real and
I don't like putting on the white coat
and donning all the pretentious [ __ ]
of doctoring so I feel like that's why I
have such meaningful interactions with
my patients because they know that I'm
human and that I don't buy into all the
trappings of you know so I'm hoping that
we came in and I think that's what's
made me that capable of being open to
other method this whole thing if the
doctor is God and we're supposed to be
micromanaging every aspect of patient's
life I don't like that I want to empower
the patients to make their own good
decisions about their wellness I try to
just give them menu of options and
things that might be helpful and then we
decide together rather than me sitting
on a pedestal ordering them around you
know so that's always worked well for me
and my mom and I know the patients
especially with my mom she's like an
incredible physician I was really lucky
to be
by her for so long I learned so much so
yeah keep mystery appreciate your time
man God thank you huh you got it but
whoa
thanks that room for two and we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
check out the links to Sue's work in the
bio below please check it out support
and also check out the links to new West
Summit as well in the bio below also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the leaders the community organizers
across the world that you believe and
support them help them grow you can
support simulation our links are below
to our show as well and also go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world catalyze this
emergent Renaissance that's happening we
love you very much we'll see you soon
yeah good job I was fun you're such a
good interviewer and sweet we should
we'll do round two one after MDMA yeah I
sure would be helpful
[Music]
you
[Music]